c'est un vrai petit coin de paradis pour
les phoques du cercle arctique
la température moyenne est de -25 degrés
bienvenue à longueur by la ville la plus
proche du pôle nord depuis quelques
années cette ancienne cité minière
développe une nouvelle activité le
tourisme
pas facile pourtant d'attirer les
clients avec un tel climat
heureusement il ya les ours 3000 bêtes
sauvages vivent 6 6 sur cette île grande
comme irlande
pas question de partir sans arbre c'est
trop dangereux dans les magasins le
merchandising autour de l'ours polaire
bat son plein et tant pis si la majorité
de ces pots est importée du canada
l'essentiel c'est d'y croire les clients
veulent du frisson mais qui achètent ces
produits liés à l'ours polaire tout le
monde c'est notre produit le plus vendu
vous en voyez beaucoup arrêts l'homme
qui a vu l'ours
le voici devenu guide il est chargé de
protéger les touristes
les ours sont essentiellement sur la
côte est
là où il ya de la banquise enfin ils
sont partout et puis seulement sur la
glace sans d anne schoor paraissent la
peur de l'ours fait vendre aujourd'hui
elle doit conduire touristes norvégiens
pour un safari dans l'archipel le
concept est efficace et les clients
nombreux une heure un jour une semaine
seul ou à 20 vous pouvez choisir votre
formule pour 200 euros par jour et par
personne
la balade sont les glaciers et dont les
cagnottes 110 g vaut le détour
ici il n'ya ni chars neige c'est unique
c'est une destination est très privé en
norvège un retour à la nature une
expérience vraiment enrichissante dans
ce désert de glace et de neige
nos touristes norvégiens n'ont pas
rencontré d'ours tout juste ont-ils pu
se consoler avec ses rennes 2
hallebardes le temps d'une pause café
dans le port glacé d'une des mines
désaffectées
il faut déjà rentrés il est près de 22
heures en cette saison
le soleil ne se couche jamais